We all understand that
she sat down on the bus.
The narrow narrative of her
just on one day did something,
couldn't be further
from the truth.
Often, the man is out front,
and you never
hear about the wife.
Here, the reverse is true.
She was considered a threat,
espousing radical views.
If they could see her
talking about the
Republic of New Africa,
her out there with the Panthers.
Then they would understand
the real Rosa Parks.
But they might have been
just a little frightened.
She has been an activist
for over three decades.
For Ms. Parks,
it was especially dangerous.
Fighting on issues that are
still very much
at the forefront.
She never gave up.
She lit the torch
to the next generation.